hey everyone
welcome to simply learns youtube channel
in this session
we will be covering the object oriented
programming in java
in this tutorial we will discuss the
following concepts
classes and objects access modifiers
inheritance and protected access
modifiers
encapsulation abstract classes interface
multiple inheritance in java using
interfaces and finally
we will cover some of the projects based
on our learnings that is
atm project and calculator project so
before we begin
make sure that you have subscribed to
our youtube channel and don't forget to
hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn
hello guys this is vikesh and let's get
started with today's topic which is
about classes and objects in java
so like i have been promising in the
previous sessions that i will cover this
in a dedicated session and
this is a session where we will go
deeper into the concept
of classes and objects you have been
seeing this keyword all along in the all
the sessions wherever i ran the
different examples and let's understand
what this means
technically if you go by the definition
a class
is basically a blueprint of an object
which brings the question as what is
object an object is basically an
instance of the class i know this
becomes more confusing so let's break it
down
into simpler definitions a class is
technically a logical entity it's
you can think of it as any entity in the
world
if you have to let's say if you have to
build a student management system or a
college management system
then all the real life objects which you
see we always say that java
is heavily inspired from real life
examples and classes and objects
are the reason we say that because
whatever you see
in the world is always basically
some entity human beings are an entity
cars are an
entity students are an entity lecturers
are an entity
so who are all the actors all the actors
which you see
in the world are basically entities and
you can map them
as classes in the java program now why
do you want to map them because
these entities have basically two
kind of specifications one is
every entity will have some attributes
and it will have some behavior
and actually that is how you identify an
entity for example
human beings have attributes like we
have hands we have eyes we have
ears legs etc these are our attributes
then we have our behaviors behaviors are
actions
you can think of them as a human being
can speak
so can speak is an action it's a
behavior can listen
is an is an action it's a behavior can
walk is an action is a behavior
similarly can eat is also an action or a
behavior so
that's how you basically represent an
entity that's how basically you identify
an entity that an entity
will have some attributes and some
behavior
if you see those two specifications in
any entity
you can map that entity or you can write
that entity
inside a java program as a class because
a class in java will exactly have these
two properties
it will have some attributes which we
call as properties
and it will have some behaviors which
technically are called as
methods so it will have attributes it
will have properties
and methods similar to real-world entity
where we have attributes and behavior
behavior our methods and attributes are
properties
that's how it is so if you if you apply
this simple philosophy whenever you are
taking requirements from a customer for
a particular project
always try to identify these entities
these actors in your program
once you have identified those you will
be able to
write a corresponding java class in your
java program which can represent those
entities
without representation of those entities
you cannot write the program
so java will kind of force you to think
in this direction to find entities
which will have attributes and behaviors
so taking that philosophy further and
taking that example further
here for you i have prepared an example
where i am creating
a student class so basically let's say
if you have to build
a college management system or a student
management system
then student is probably one of the main
entities which will be
talked about when you take the
requirements so if you think about the
attributes and the behavior concept
a student will have a name will have an
age
will have an address and at the same
time a student
can also have some behaviors like can
enroll in a particular course can attend
a lecture
can take a leave can take exam etc
these are all behaviors let's understand
this in a more detail with the help of
this example where i've created a class
which is named as student and you see
the public keyword here
again i will cover access modifier
public is basically an access modifier
and i will cover this in very detail in
the upcoming sessions
for now let's focus on this part so we
have created a class
to represent our entity you put a curly
braces around it
it ends here and after that you provide
the attributes so here i'm saying that a
student
will have a name it will have an age and
it will have an
address it has three properties so the
technical
name of attributes is properties after
that
let's skip this part and i will come
back to this part once you have declared
these properties
you would want to provide a way
for the name to be filled or replaced
or received for example if you have
created the student class how do you
insert the name inside the student class
or how do you insert the age or how do
you insert the address or modify the age
name or address
properties for that we have these
setters and getters methods we call them
setters and getters because they start
with
this keyword not keyword but they start
with a string called set it is not a
keyword you can actually write it as
anything you can call it as modify name
that will also be absolutely fine java
will not give you an error
but the standard naming convention given
by java is to
start the methods as starting with set
and get this is the
this is the standard naming convention
and like i said it's a naming convention
it's not a compulsion
but if you write this way your
co-developers
and the people who are going to maintain
this project in the long run will be
very happy
otherwise they will be very angry if you
use strange methods because like i said
this is the standard naming convention
so now you are going to
write a setter method for each of the
properties
in this particular class for name age
and address
so we call set name again you put public
void because this is not supposed to
return anything this is just supposed to
set the value of name
with whatever value you specified then
you call set name
and then you provide the value which you
are supposed to set
against the name so whatever value like
any random name john or jane whatever
you need to supply that name here value
while you call this method
and that name uh whatever you name you
supply will be set
against the name property of this
particular class
and remember i use the word this here
intentionally
because the way you are going to
represent this
is with the help of this keyword this
keyword means
current object it means that you are as
when you use this dot name it is
referring to the current object's name
property
and this name is basically corresponding
to the name which is coming in
when somebody is trying to set a name
similarly for set age age is a numeric
number if you if you observed
it's basically an integer then i'm
saying age and whatever value of age
will be coming will be set in this
particular
object's age then similarly
for set address we have a string address
argument being passed into into this
method
and this gets set inside the current
object's address property
so i have provided a way for the
external world to set the values
of name age and address because for each
student you would need to set these
values
now you also need to provide a way to
receive the values or to return the
values or to read the values
for reading operation you need to
provide the getter method
so you see this get again this is not a
keyword it's a standard naming
convention
so similar when you when you wrote set
name similarly you will write a get name
method
this get name method is supposed to be
reading the current object's names
properties value
and will return that value since name is
a string that's why you see
the return type as string here similarly
get
age is going to return the age which is
an integer and
address is going to return the address
you can also write it
like this which is absolutely fine it is
not going to complain
because technically it is returning the
current objects name properties and age
property and the
address property now let's talk about
this
what is what is this section so this
section is basically called
a constructor and i have a whole session
dedicated on the constructors
but let's understand why we need this
remember when i told you the definition
of the class i said that class is a
blueprint
of an object so you have created a
student class and you have 5000 students
in your college
now you need to create a new student
object
for each of those student you need to
initialize this
student class 5000 times how do you do
that
to do that we do that with the help of
constructors we call this constructor
this is a special type of method
remember this is a special type of
method which is provided by java
to initialize any classes objects
if you want to create multiple objects
of the student class
you can repeatedly call this student
constructor we call this
constructor so you put public here
because we want this constructor to be
accessible to the outside world
then you put the exact class name so
whatever class name you have provided
here
you need to put the exact class name
here if you don't do that
java is going to raise an error if i do
this here
it is going to you see a red line here
because java failed to compile this
constructor it does not understand what
is student triple one
but it does understand what is student
so this is how it is going to be
and then you provide all the properties
which are going to create the student
object so you're going to create the
name
the age and the address so the name age
and address and then you set those
values again
similar to the setter methods we have
seen the reason we need to use this here
because
if you don't if you write it like this
then java doesn't understand the
difference between the current object's
name and the name coming from the
argument so to differentiate that you
need to use this here
if you use n here and if i just use n
here then this is fine because
there's only single name variable in
this whole class then
but if i write it like this then and if
i write it like this
then java doesn't know if this name is
basically the student class's name
or this name is student classes name it
will get confused like you are getting
confused
if you if you try to just find this in
mind mapping
so that's why we need to write this here
so that it's clearly differentiable that
whenever i use this dot name
i'm referring to the classes name
property and when i'm just using the
name
i'm referring to the method argument
that's what we do in doing this
in this constructor so you basically
initialize all the properties
of your class with some values with the
help of
constructor so we have the constructor
we have the setter we have the getter
we can cover about this two string
basically this two string is to print
print something but we can cover that
later now uh
let's initialize this particular class
so i'm similar to the initialization we
have seen so far
you just write student you write the
object name this can be anything
and then you use the new keyword which
is used to initialize anything in java
new is a keyword in java which you can
use to initialize literally anything in
java
so you use new student and when you say
new student you can provide all the
values
which should match its constructor so
here we have three values
string integer and string and here also
we are supplying three values string
integer
and string again so remember to match
this exactly
with one of the constructors which is
available in the class
if it doesn't match it is going to fail
it will not work so if i for example if
i do
this then i'm supplying four arguments
to the student class
but there is no constructor matching
four arguments so it is going to
complain
you see this red line and the code is
not compiling if i remove this then it
is matching it
and that's how you basically create a
student object so
an object is basically an instance of
the class remember that very well an
object is an instance of the class once
you have created an instance of the
class
then you can call any method like say
let's say you want to read the name so
you can call
get name you can read the name similarly
if you want to
so if you if you want to read the age of
this
student then you can do that as well so
let me just copy this
and do this let's call get
age i want to print the name i want to
print the age
and i also want to print the address so
get control space i get suggestion
address
yep so i'm printing the name i'm
printing the age and i'm printing the
address after i have
initialized the object successfully by
using this constructor representation
using the new keyword so now let's run
this method
or run this class basically okay so
when i run this class the whole class
got compiled the constructor the getters
and the setters and the properties and
their types everything was set
then the main got called and i created a
new object
from this classes blueprint the object
name was john
then i called john.getname to print the
name which is stored inside this
particular instance of the student class
similarly the age of age which is stored
in
this particular instance so we stored
the name as john
so when we call john.getname we get john
we got when we call john.getpage we get
the age25 and
we call john.getaddress we call we get
this particular address
whatever values you specified here the
constructor got called here
and the name john got set to the
student's
name value the age value which you
supplied got set against the students
age
and the address value which you supplied
got set against the student's address
and that's how you are going to create a
class so remember whenever you create a
class
identify the properties and the
behaviors like setters and getters
write a constructor which can cover all
the values which you want to initialize
and after that just initialize that
class
create an object of that particular
class basically and once you have the
object then you can call getters
you can also call this in this way if i
don't supply any of this
then it currently it complains and why
it complains
i will cover that in the following
session when whenever when i will cover
the multiple constructors concept
but remember you see this behavior here
that if you have created a constructor
which accepts some arguments
and if you supply this kind of
initialization
then student class does not have a
constructor which is parameter less
student class has only one constructor
which is taking three parameters
and that's why java complains because it
is not able to find
a representation of a constructor which
accepts no parameter
but like i said we will cover this we
will find a solution to this particular
problem
in the in the coming uh in the coming
session but for this session this is all
we are going to cover we covered about
classes we covered about
objects and we also saw how we can write
getters and setters we can initialize
those methods
uh initialize those objects and we can
access the properties of
those objects using the getters and we
can also call the setters to modify the
values as well similar to this
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description
to know more let's get started with
access modifiers in java
so when we talk about access modifiers
let's understand what is the underlying
philosophy of
the reasoning behind this and the
reasoning is very straightforward it can
be even wrapped into a single word
which is called security the reason is
that
you will be creating multiple kinds of
objects and variables
while you write your java program and
you should always
write your java program or any program
in a manner that
only the intended classes packages
modules or applications should be able
to see what they are supposed to see so
as a consumer application
i should only be able to consume the
variables
which i am expected to consume i should
not get any variable or i should not
even have access to any variable
which i am not supposed to access so the
idea is
providing the least privileged principle
give access to different functions
different variables different programs
only by providing them the kind of
access which they need to run
efficiently and do not give them
complete access so with that notion in
mind
java created the concept of access
modifiers and it created these
three modifiers which are called public
protected
and private if you do not provide any
modifier then it goes to
no modifier or some people also call it
as default modifier which is also a type
of access modifier
so let's understand theoretically first
how it works and then we will try to
have a look at an example
let's understand the first one first of
all these modifiers are keywords
and you can use these keywords in front
of classes
in front of variables and also in front
of
methods and you might have already
noticed this particular keyword called
public
in front of all the classes i've created
or even when we talked about the
public static void main method we saw
this public as a keyword
it is basically an access modifier and
whenever you put public in front of a
class or a variable or a method
that particular component becomes
available
to the whole of the program it will be
available to
the whole world basically any subclass
or any package or any other class which
might have been written in your java
program will be able to access that
particular class or variable or method
if you put public in front of that the
second
modifier level is protected
one of the other thing which you you
will understand as i explain this
is that as you move down into this
particular table
the access level will start getting more
and more restricted
by restriction i mean that less and less
components will be able to get access to
those modifiers so if you write
protected in front of a class or in
front of a method or in front of a
variable
then everything within that particular
class will still be able to access it
everything within the package will still
be able to access it
i still haven't covered the concept of
package but i briefly touched upon it
showing you how whenever we write a
class we have a package in front of it
and package is technically
is just an aggregation of the classes if
you have to ripe
write multiple classes and wrap all of
those classes into a single logical
bundle
that would be called a package just to
show you an example these all are
packages which you see here
you see this square box here and you see
that these names these all are packages
and these packages contain multiple
classes and
technically that's all the packages mean
that you can wrap
multiple related classes into a single
package so coming back to the access
modifier
whenever you write protected in front of
a class or a variable or a method
then that particular component will be
accessible to
everybody within the same class
everybody within the same package
it will also be accessible to everybody
which is a subclass of the class
this is again a new concept which i have
not covered but this basically means
a child of this class now what is a
child of the class we will cover
at that concept in detail when we will
talk about inheritance
but for now you can understand that it
is a basically an extension
of the class so when the moment you
declare something is protected it can
easily be accessible within the same
class in which this protected component
was declared
it can be accessed in the package it can
also be accessed in the subclasses
of the class but anything outside the
package
will not be able to access it because
you see an n here
then we have the default access modifier
or no modifier
if you do not write anything in front of
a class or a method or a variable
it gets the default access modifier
privileges
and that privilege mean that anybody
within the same class
will be able to access that default
variable
or a default component anybody within
the package will also be able to access
it
the subclasses of the class where the
default component was declared
those sub classes will not be able to
access it and
anybody outside the package will
obviously not be able to access it
then comes the last one which is the
most restricted privilege which is
called private
so if you put private in front of a
class or in front of a method or in
front of a variable
that component will only be accessible
within the class
where it was declared it will not be
accessible
in the package it will not be accessible
in the subclasses
and definitely not be accessible to
anybody outside the package
so private is the least privileged or
least
access permission level you have in java
once you write private in front of any
component
that only the the classes other
variables the the same class in which
you declare this particular private
variable
only that class itself will be able to
access it and nobody else will be able
to access it
and as you move above the accesses
become more and more lenient you can see
it is just
one y and three n here the moment you
move a bit above to the default modifier
you get two y's so everybody in the
class and everybody in the package will
be able to access
that particular component rest of for
the rest of the other
world it is still unknown when you write
something as protected
then everything in the class everything
in the package and everything in the
subclasses will
also be able to access it rest of the
world cannot access it
and if you write something as public
then anybody can access it
it's like why everywhere so that is how
the access levels work
now let us understand this with the help
of example so i will go here
and i've just written a very simple
dummy class here which has
uh which is a class called test and i
have a method here which is
a display method so very simple class
nothing fancy here and if you
if you notice i have not put any kind of
public
private or uh or protected modifier in
front of the class
so this will get the default privilege
if something has default privilege
then the whole world will not be able to
access it so
let's go to a different package let's go
to this package which is here
and let's try to access this particular
test class so we will try to access this
test.java
here in the main class so let's try to
do that
let's say test t equal to new test i'm
just
initializing the same class so what do i
get
i get a compile error let me try to fix
it if i can
and i cannot fix it if you see i'm just
trying to use this particular test class
into a different package
but that package is not able to see the
class at all i'm getting a compilation
error and if i
try to click on the error generally
eclipse provide me suggestions
to fix the to import this particular
class but eclipse is not able to find
and find any class with the name of test
which can be imported in this package
which is a different package than the
one of the test class so we cannot
access it because it's in the default
access
now let's go back to the test class and
let's make it public
so i've just made it public here and now
if i click on this
again i get the suggestion if you see
the suggestion was not there earlier now
it says import test
and if i click on this double click it
gets imported
and everything is happy so you can see
the whole access modifier in effect here
the default walls is versus public you
can also try the other
other kind of access modifiers let's try
private as well i think private will
also have the same effect because it
will still not be accessible
from the package or from the subclass
from or from the uh from the whole world
we already saw this particular in effect
but we will see the private in a in a
different way now
so going back to the test class i have
made the class as
public but the method here is default
i have not exposed this method to be
used outside
the class let's see what happens if i
try to call this
display method from the main class so i
have successfully initialized the class
and if i say
t dot and if i look at the suggestions
here
i do not get the suggestion of the
display method
why because it is default if i go back
make it private can i now access it
let's try again nope still we can't
access it eclipse is not even able to
find it inside this package
because it is private let's go back
and make it public so i've made it just
public now
going back to the main class and again
saying t dot now i get the display
suggestion as the first suggested method
here and now i
am able to use the display method once i
have made it public
so you see the moment you change the uh
the access modifiers
the changes are propagated immediately
and you can see the public versus
default versus private in play here we
can even go into further detail by using
the protected but for protected i have
to explain the concept of subclasses
so i will cover this protected versus
subclasses concept when i talk about
inheritance and there we will see the
usage of protected variables
and the protected access modifier but we
saw the usage of public
the default modifier and the private
modifier
do check out the documentation for these
access modifiers and i would strongly
suggest you to play around with this
get more comfortable with this concept
of different kind of modifiers
let's also run an example for for
understanding the default modifier in a
better sense
because we can see that for the package
it says why right so let's go back to
eclipse
and within the same package where we
created test class let's create another
class
let's call it test demo
so i will just click finish i get a new
class
let me also write the public static void
main method here
so i get the public static void main
method here and let's try to access
the test class here within the same
package so
let me again go back to the default
privilege here
so i put the test class access as the
default class
or default access and same goes for
display so can
other classes in the same package access
the test class now
let's see that if i go to test demo and
here if i try to
get the test class initialize does it
work or does it give me a compilation
error yes it works
it works because the test class and the
test demo are in the same package
and test class has that default access
privilege
so let's try to run one more variation
of it to understand the usage of the
private method better
going back to the test class this
display method has the
default privilege right now so going by
that logic
if i say t dot i should be able to get
access to the display method
and yes that is possible if i run this
particular program
i will be able to get whatever is given
out by the display method
which is hello world now let's try to
make this particular method as
private and let's try to access this
method
from one of the other class in the same
package as of the test class
the class is default the method is
private and if you see this class has
already turned red
there is a compilation error because now
the display method
is not accessible to the testdemo class
even if it was in the same package
it's not accessible because the display
methods privilege or access modifier
has gone to private now exactly the same
as explained here
because it has become private so the
package level members
cannot access it there's an n here so
this is this was another variation to
show you how you can use
public protected and private together to
only
expose the members methods and classes
which are supposed to be exposed to the
consumer this is a very critical and
very important concept
to be used in java and it is used from a
very simple program
to all the highly complex application
this is sort of the
bare bone or the laying foundation for
any kind of basic security level premise
which you need to build your application
let's get started with inheritance so
inheritance is basically
one of the most important properties of
any object-oriented programming language
it's basically a concept and the concept
says
that what if you have a scenario where
you want multiple classes to share
similar behavior
and similar properties let's understand
this with the help of an example
let's take the example of a bank when
you go to a bank to open an account
there are multiple types of accounts
there can be a savings account
it can be a type of current account
there can also be a different offering
for personal account
and commercial accounts such as for
businesses then you may also have loan
accounts
which are having different kind of
properties so all of these
types of accounts are still technically
accounts and they will share some
similar properties
for example all of them will have to
maintain some sort of an interest rate
for example
all of them will be used to either
deposit money or
withdraw money so there would be some
kind of similarity across all of these
types of account classes
but at the same time there will also be
some sort of differentiality
amongst these classes the way you will
calculate the interest rate
for a current account will be different
from the way you will calculate the
interest rate
for a savings account and the same
applies for commercial account personal
account loan account etc so
you see that we have some common
behavior but at the same time we also
have some
different behavior so whenever you have
such scenario
always think about applying the concept
of inheritance
in your application there's another
simple way to spot whether inheritance
can be used at a particular place or not
inheritance is also called is a
relationship
so whenever you read the requirements
from a customer just try to find the
words
which use this particular phrase is a
for example car is a vehicle
savings account is a type of account
similarly you will find
many other types of similar examples so
whenever you will see that
is a relationship between two different
kinds of objects or two different kind
of entities that means that there might
be
an inheritance relationship being
applied between them
and that's how you will spot the usage
of inheritance
so so far we have understood this
concept that there would be
some sort of relationship between the
two classes what will be this
relationship
the relationship will be of parent child
type there will be a parent class
some people also call that as base class
and then there will be a
child class so the child class will be
inheriting the properties and the
behaviors from the
base class or from the parent class i
will be using
base class and parent class terms
interchangeably during this session
but the basic idea and basic premise is
like that only that there will be a
child class
and there will be a parent class and the
child class class
is extending from the parents class
remember the word extend because we are
going to use that and i've just shown
you the uh
what you see here is basically the
official definition which is given by
javadocs here we can read the definition
as well
and the basic idea which i told you lies
in the parent and child relationship
and this is how you can conceptualize it
that you will have
a base class or a parent class and then
you will you can have multiple children
of it and then those children can again
have their own children
and so on so forth so this hierarchy
this whole inheritance hierarchy can go
as deep as you want it to be and that's
the basic idea and basic
conceptualization
of how you understand and how you
visualize inheritance
now let's move to eclipse ide and try to
understand this with the help of an
example
so for this particular case i have
created
a set of classes basically which we will
be using to demonstrate the relationship
of inheritance and i've taken the simple
example
of a bicycle so a bicycle is again a
very generic definition of any two
wheeler and bicycles can have multiple
types
there can be an all-terrain bike there
can be a mountain bike
there can be a city bike there can be a
bike which is specific
specifically made for ladies and
similarly there can be multiple
different types of bikes
but all of these bikes will have some
similar properties
for example all of them will have two
wheels all of them will have
a seat all of them will have brake all
of them will have
some sort of some sort of a speeding
mechanism whether they can accelerate or
de-accelerate so there will be some
commonality but at the same time
a mountain bike's features might be very
different
from a city bike feature a mountain bike
features
might feature mountain bike might have
gears for example
whereas a city bike might not have gears
because you don't need
that much of a variation in in
inclination and declination when you
drive down the road so i'm trying to
conceptualize the same example here
where i've created a class called
bicycle and this is my base class
i define two properties in the in the
bicycle class which is
gear and speed we will come back to
protected in a while
but let's let's leave that there so i
have two properties which is
gear and speed i have a constructor
where i'm initializing the
starting speed and the starting gear and
then
i have three methods here which says set
gear
apply brake and speed up when i apply
brake
the speed is going to get reduced so
that's why you see minus equal to unity
operator
and when i'm trying to speed up the
speed is going to increase
that's why i'm using the plus equal to
unity operator so when you use the
method speedup
the speed is going to be increased by
the value you supply in the method
similarly when you apply the break the
speed is going to
get reduced by the amount you supply in
the method
argument and that is my base class
bicycle
gear speed and three methods now let's
have a look at the child class
so the way you will define the
inheritance relationship in java
is by using this extends keyword
remember i told you to remember the
extends keyword
so what you will do that you will write
your class name as usual
and then you will use extends keyword
and then you will use
the parent class name or the base class
name
so here i am saying class mountain bike
extends bicycle
and here i am providing an additional
property remember the whole commonality
versus differentiality
equation so a mountain bike might have
an extra property
to adjust the seat height so that's the
extra property which mountain bike
is having and then since this
mountain bike is extending the bicycle
class
this mountain bike class has the
responsibility
to initialize the bicycle class as well
and the way it will fulfill that
responsibility
is by taking all the arguments
of bicycle class plus the mountain bike
class
in its constructor and that's why you
see three different properties here
you see the start height property which
is the
property of this particular class which
is the seat height and then you see the
start speed and start gear property
which directly are not available in this
class
but this class is inheriting those
properties from the
base class remember the keyword
inheritance here
and then once you do that how do you
initialize the base class constructor
is by calling the super method this is
again a keyword in java
and you will use this super keyword to
refer to
the base class constructor in this way
so what you will do technically
is that you will write super and you
will supply
the arguments which is required by the
base class constructor
if i go back the base class constructor
requires two arguments
start speed and start gear so i write
super
and then i write start speed and start
gear so whatever i got from here
in the constructor of mountain bike i'm
supplying those values as
is to super and java will automatically
take care of
invoking this particular constructor the
moment it
uh encounters this kind of statement
another another thing to notice is that
the super
keyword or super statement has to be the
first statement inside your constructor
remember that whenever you are dealing
with inheritance and whenever you have
to initialize
the super class constructor or the base
class constructor
use the super constructor invocation as
the very first statement
inside your child class constructor
otherwise java will not
compile the program and then you will
initialize the local variable
i should call this as this remember i we
discussed about this
in this in the classes session
okay and then it just has a method of
set height so there's no extra method
which this mountain bike is providing
but this mountain bike will have access
to
all the methods which have been provided
here and all the properties which have
been provided here
this mountain bike can access everything
from the bicycle class and that's the
whole
idea of inheritance that the child class
can
access the properties of the base class
by extending the base class
now let's look at how do we invoke this
particular class
so for that i have a simple class name
as inheritance demo which has a public
static void main method
and then i am initializing the mountain
bike class
i'm supplying three values as 20 10 and
1
so the 20 goes to start height
the 10 here goes to start speed
and one here goes to gear
or the start gear and that's how i'm
setting the values
so when i call this particular
constructor here the mountain bike
constructor is going to
this mountain bike constructor is going
to get called and
which in turn is going to call the base
class bicycle class constructor as well
and everything will be set accordingly
and then let's try to access the gear
property remember gear is not directly
available in the mountain bike class
but i'm still able to do mountain bike
dot gear because
child class can access the parent's
class properties
similarly the same thing goes for speed
as well
and seat height is the local property of
this particular class mountain bike
so it will anyways be accessible so i
can access
all the properties of the base class and
the child class itself
seamlessly without any differentiation
now let's try to
call a method so here i'm calling the
method apply break
remember apply break was defined in the
base class not in the child class
it's defined here so i'm calling the
apply break method
and i want to reduce the speed the
current speed by
one and then i'm printing the current
speed saying that bike speed after
applying break is
mountain bike dot speed so let's run
this particular program and observe the
outputs
okay so the the first statement which
gets printed is at line number seven
which says gear is
one because it's coming from here then
the seat height
is mountain bike dot seat height which
is 20 which is the first argument
here and then the bike speed is 10 which
is coming as here
and getting printed here and then when i
apply the brake
let's go back to the apply brake method
the logic is that whatever is the
current speed
reduce it by the value i supply in the
method
so if i supply 1 10 minus 1 becomes 9
and that becomes the current speed
if i supply 5 here the current speed
will be 10 minus 5 equal to 5.
let's assert that particular assumption
as well yes we can see that
and similarly you can access other
methods of the base class as well
if i just do control space here and you
can see apply break
is accessible set gear set height speed
up
all the methods which are defined in the
base class are accessible
in the child class as well this is the
power of inheritance
one more thing which i said i will come
back to is around the usage of protected
access modifier remember when we
discussed about the access modifiers in
the previous session
i said that protected is used when you
are dealing with inheritance
that whenever you define something as
protected it will be available
to be accessible in the child classes of
the base class
so if i define this particular variable
as as protected
then this particular property will be
accessible in the child class
mountain bike as well let's play around
this let's make this as private and see
what happens
so if i make this private now when i say
private the
scope of this particular variable is
within the class only and nobody outside
the class will be able to see it
and you can see the effect of it i can
see an error being coming here in my
inheritance demo class
because now mountain bike object cannot
access the gear property
because the gear property is defined in
the base class and now it is private
that's why the child class now mountain
bike class cannot access
the property gear and the moment you
make make it back to
protected it will be accessible the
error is gone there's no red line here
so that's how you can you can use the
protected
access modifiers it is always always
recommended to use them when you when
you
write any kind of inheritance logic and
inheritance logic as well intentionally
if you want to hide a particular
property from the child classes just
make it private
and that's all i want to cover in this
particular session where we
dive deep into the concept of
inheritance we had a look at an example
using the bicycle and mountain bike
kind of construct and you can apply the
same kind of construct on any kind of
other
other kind of business requirement
remember there is a relationship
let's get started with encapsulation so
again let's understand what is
encapsulation in general and then we
will apply that concept
to java encapsulation if you try to
break that word if i just
write it here in the form of a comment
it's n capsulation just trying to break
this word
into to make it more visual so you see
you see a word called capsule here
so if you try to imagine a capsule
why do you create that and what's the
concept of a capsule
capsule tries to pack a lot of things
inside a small
tube-like shape and the concept of
encapsulation
is sort of inspired from that not
exactly not
literally but that's the basic idea of
of this root word which is called
encapsulation
so encapsulation basically means to
restrict accessing the properties of
a class to the outside world if you want
to
protect the properties of your class
how do you do that you do that with the
help of the concept
called encapsulation so here you this is
a sort of a security feature you can
think of a
think of it as a security feature that
you want to protect
the properties of your class and you
will use
encapsulation to protect the properties
how you implement encapsulation let's
have a look at that now
so basic idea is to encapsulate
the objects create sort of a capsule
around the object
which can provide that protection layer
and you will define
how the outside world is going to access
the properties
of the class if needed so i've created a
simple class here
and it's if you if you remember one of
the previous examples when we discussed
about classes
i used the same class which was the
student class and i'm just using the
same class for continuity so
i have created a student class here and
i have created three different
properties
of this particular class which is name
name of the student
age of the student and address of the
student
you see intentionally i have used the
keyword
private in front of these three
properties
and that is the first thing which you
need to do to
implement encapsulation on your object
that you hide all the properties from
the outside world
remember the moment you make anything is
private only the class which is the
student class itself
only the class itself can see these
variables
or these properties nothing outside the
student class will be able to
access the name or age or the address
directly from the student class it's not
possible that's the whole idea of making
it private because you don't want the
outside world
to access these properties so you make
those properties as
private then you create a constructor
the constructor has to be public
so that anybody can initialize the
student object because you want your
object to be accessible
remember so you want the objects to be
accessible but you want
the restriction on the access of the
properties of the object and these are
the properties of the object
so you have restricted them by making it
private but that doesn't solve the
problem
because there will be some illegitimate
consumers of the student object
which should not have access to the
student properties
but there will also be some legitimate
consumers of the student object
which should be having access to the
properties of the student
for example the payroll application will
need access
to these particular properties the
examination application
will require access to these particular
properties
so how do you do that you create getters
we call them getters because they start
with the keyword
get so you create a getter method for
each of the property
you create the method called as get name
and this is the naming convention with
java promotes
that you write get and then you write
the name of the property
in camel case so you write get name
and this property is supposed to return
the name
property of this particular object and
you here you say
return name so you're returning the the
name which is
being stored by the current student
object whenever somebody calls
student object dot get name and this is
the way
you have restricted the access of this
particular object as well
so remember you made it private so that
nobody can access it
and then you defined your own way of
providing access to the name property
of this particular class now if anybody
wants to access the name value of your
student object
there's only one and one way to do that
which is via calling get name so you
have provided
restrictions and you have also provided
prescriptive guidance
on how you are going to expose the
properties of your class
that's the second uh thing which you
need to do
to implement correct form of
encapsulation
on your object that that is to provide
the getter methods
with the right visibility you want to
make them public so that anybody can
call them
but since you are governing which is
what is written inside the method
you have full control on what kind of
exposure you want to give for this
particular property
similarly you create a getter for age
calling getage
which returns the age and then you call
get
you write get address and return the
address
here it is simply returning it but if
you want to do more stuff here
feel free to do that like i said you
govern the control
of how do you want to return the name
maybe you don't want to return the
complete name and you want to just
return
the initials then you can split the
string
trim the string and return only the
initials so that's the basic idea of
getters
now after you have created the object
there might be use cases
where somebody needs to overwrite the
values of the properties
like name age or address whatever
student's name was incorrectly mentioned
when they called the constructor and now
they want to
overwrite the name or fix the name so
basically they have to replace the
existing value of the name
with a new name so in that case you need
to provide what we call as
setters and they start with set that's
why we call them setters
and we follow the same kind of logic
that you provide the setters
for all the properties of your class so
you had three properties
which were named age and address and you
provided the setters for
all three of them and how do you provide
that you write you again make them as
public because you want the outside
world to access
this setter method to overwrite the
values of the name this method is not
going to return anything so it is going
to be void
then you write the name of the method
which starts with set and then the
property name in camel case
and then you provide the new value which
is the value which should be
which should be the new value and this
is the value which should replace the
existing value so whatever new value you
want to supply
you supply that as the argument of the
setter methods for set name
for set age or for set address
and then you write this particular line
which says
set the current name property of this
particular
object with the name which is coming in
from the
argument so this dot name remember this
dot name
represents the current object's property
because this represents the current
object
so whatever is the current object
property value
of the name is just override that value
with the argument coming in do the same
thing for age and set age method
and do the same thing for set address in
the
in the set address method so this is how
you are going to provide the setters
and the getters so setters and getters
can also be generated in smart id
is light like eclipse so you just right
click you go to source
and here you will see the option of
generate getters and setters
if you click on this it will give you
the list of the fields which
are available to be had to be having
getters and setters
currently it says no fields or all
fields have getters and setters already
yes because they have it
let me just comment this and show this
how this work so
for example let me comment all the
getters and setters
so i'm commenting them and if i right
click
source generate getters and setters
i get all the fields available for which
setters and getters can be generated
so you can select them and leave
everything
as default hit generate and it is
automatically going to generate the
getters and the setter you see
all the code of the getter and setter is
automatically generated
you do not even need to write it and
this is the power of the smart ideas
let me just revert what i did
so you created everything as all the
properties as private
and then you define how you want to
replace the values by providing the
setters
and you define how you want the outside
world to
access your properties so you have full
control of the class now
you you control the visibility you
control how they are going to get
initialized
you are you are controlling how the
properties are going to be overwritten
or
set and you control how the properties
are going to be returned
so you have complete control of the
class so you have created a perfect
capsule here
a perfect form of encapsulation in this
class and this is how you can implement
encapsulation
let's get started with abstraction let's
first understand the definition of
abstraction
before we relate this to java
abstraction generally
means hiding something when you want to
hide some details
of of a particular object from the
outside world
you apply the concept of abstraction for
example
when you drive a particular car you just
hit
the accelerator and the car speeds up
now it's not only one action when you
hit the accelerator
the whole machinery of the car and all
the components
different parts of the car work together
to speed up they would be engine there
would be propulsion there would be fuel
there would be
there might be some if it's an electric
car they would batteries
uh there would be whole different kinds
of pistons and plugs which will make
the car speed up it's not only a single
component it's
a lot of different components under the
hood and
that's the concept of abstraction that
we only show
the relevant parts to the user and we
hide all the internal details
from the user that's the basic idea of
abstraction so a car manufacturer
abstracts away all the inner technical
details from the driver
and just gives the driver a single pedal
to speed up the car
for a user it's a very good experience
because he doesn't need to know about
all the internals of the car
but the car manufacturer can hide all
the details and provide a very simple
interface
for the driver to interact with which is
just a gas pedal
and that's the basic idea of abstraction
and we try to apply the same kind of
concept
to java in the form of abstraction and
java provides this
kind of concept implementation with the
help of
a keyword which is called abstract now
abstract is a keyword which can be used
in front of a class
or a method when you use it in front of
a class
the whole class becomes abstract
abstract class is a type of class
so the class itself becomes an abstract
class
one of the things to remember is that
abstract class cannot be
instantiated but can be subclassed
remember we talked about the concept of
subclass and the parent class when we
talked about inheritance
so if you make a class as abstract class
you cannot
call the constructor of the class
because you cannot instantiate it
but you can extend the abstract class
and create a child class
class out of it that's the concept of
abstract class
another concept is abstract method you
can also use the abstract keyword
in front of a method and when you use
abstract keyword in front of a method
then that method is only declared
without an
implementation you are not going to
provide any implementation of the method
and you're just going to declare the
method something like this
we will see a similar example in the in
the hands on as well but that's the
basic idea that you just
declare the method you are not providing
an implementation as to what does move
to method actually does
because that's the whole concept of
abstraction and it is the responsibility
of the child classes
which inherit the particular class in
which the abstract method would be
sitting
so that child class will be having the
responsibility to provide
a concrete implementation of the
declared
method let's understand this better with
the help of an example
so here i have created a class called
graphic
object and i have made the class as
abstract class this is the keyword which
you need to use in front before the
class
keyword and the task becomes an abstract
class
now when you create an abstract class it
automatically gets some properties
the first property is that this
particular class
must have at least one abstract method
and this is how you define the abstract
methods where you just provide the
declaration but you do not provide the
implementation of the draw method or the
resize method
and the way you will create the abstract
methods is by using the abstract keyword
before the actual method declaration
starts so general method declaration
would look like this
and if you use abstract in front of it
this becomes an abstract
method declaration abstract class can
also have concrete methods
so that is the liberty which abstract
class gives you that you can have
abstract methods which are just declared
but you can also have normal methods
which are which where you can also
provide the implementation
so you can have normal methods and
abstract methods as well in an abstract
class
so this is the abstract class now if
if you want to provide an implementation
of the draw and resize method
you have to extend this abstract class
so we extend this abstract class by
creating two
child classes out of this particular
abstract class which is
circle.java where you can see i create a
normal class
and i use the extends keyword for
inheritance and i'm saying that circle
class is inheriting from the
graphic object class which was my
abstract class
and once i use this extends keyword then
i have the responsibility of providing
the implementation
of the abstract methods actually java
will force me to provide the
implementation of these two methods
if i do not provide all the declared
methods so there are two declared
methods here
so if the circuit class does not provide
that
the implementation for both draw and
resize methods
then java will throw an error and it
will ask you to take an action
which can be either define all the
methods
meaning provide implementation for all
the methods or
make the circle class itself as abstract
let's see if i just comment this
particular out i get an error you see a
red line
here and if you click on this particular
balloon here it will say either
you can add the unimplemented methods or
you can make the circle type as
abstract these are the two options which
you will get to fix this particular
error
so an abstract class can be extended by
another abstract class
if the child abstract class is not
implementing all the methods of the
parent
if you want to implement all the methods
then just implement them and keep
that keep it as a normal class and
that's what i've done here i've just
created a normal class here
and provided the implementation and once
you provide the implementation of both
of the methods
the error is gone similarly i have also
provided another child class
because it's uh there can be there can
be multiple children
of a particular parent so rectangle also
extends from the graphic object
and it also provides its own
implementation of drawing and resize
because generally the way you will draw
a rectangle and you resize a rectangle
will be different than drawing or
resizing a circle
here i'm not doing anything in the
methods because this is just to show you
the demonstration i'm just printing a
cis out saying drawing a circle
and resizing or drawing a rectangle and
resizing a rectangle
and in the circle class drawing a circle
and resizing
a circle so one abstract class is the
parent class which is the
graphic object and two children circle
and rectangle
both providing the implementation of the
abstract methods
which were declared in the base class
now let's go to the main class
where i've defined defined the public
static void main method
and here you see i have created two
different kind of
blocks of code here one block is where
i'm saying graphic
object creating a reference of the
graphic object
named as circle and initializing the
circle
object now you see a difference here
here is the abstract class
and here is the concrete class so
whatever you define
on the right hand side whatever is the
type of object
will be the type of methods being caught
so if you created a circle object
and then if you call the draw method and
resize method
these methods will be called from the
circle class
if you initialized it as new rectangle
then you are creating a rectangle
class object and then the draw and the
resize method will be called from the
rectangle class that's the basic
construct and that's how you will
initialize a particular class which is
using an abstract class
so i i call a graphic object circle new
circle and i call circle.draw and circle
dot resize
similarly graphic object rectangle equal
to new rectangle
and rectangle.draw rectangle dot resize
let's run this program and observe the
output so when i call this particular
block of code
circle object gets initialized and then
circle.draw method prints
drawing a circle and circle dot resize
method prints
drawing resizing a circle similarly when
i create the rectangle class object
referencing it with the graphic object
class rectangle.draw
prints this particular line drawing a
rectangle
and rectangle.resize prints this
particular line which is
resizing a rectangle and this is how you
will use the concept of abstraction
there's another very interesting thing
which which is which is going on here
remember i told you that the abstract
classes cannot be instantiated
so if i go here and i try to create a
constructor of the
graphic object class let's see what
happens
if i do this and i i create i just put a
system out here
base abstract plus so if i do this here
if i create
if i still write a constructor though
java says that it cannot be instantiated
if i still write a constructor of it and
i do not
do any changes here and if i run this
particular program
let's see what happens you'll see the
base abstract class being called here
let me just reformat it by putting ln
here so that
we get a better output so if i run this
particular program
you see base abstract class is getting
printed somehow
though we said that abstract classes
cannot be instantiated but still the
constructor of this is still getting
called somehow
when i create a circle class the base
class constructor gets called and when i
cl
create a rectangle class again the base
class constructor gets called
this is this is the power of inheritance
because in inheritance
remember how it works when you call when
you initialize a particular
child object referencing it with the
parent object
see the references of the parent class
and the object is of the child class
so whenever you do it like this first
the
default constructor because i'm calling
the default constructor here
the default constructor of the circle
class will get called
which will go here remember i told you
that java provides the default
constructor automatically
if you don't provide it so the default
constructor of circle gets called
but java sees that you are writing this
code here which says circle
extends graphic object so java is
automatically
going to call the parent class and going
to initialize the parent class as well
because that's how it will be able to
see these methods
and so so that's why it will
automatically call the base class
constructor even if you don't call it
explicitly
in fact you cannot call it explicitly
java will not allow you to
initialize the graphic object class
explicitly it can only and only be
called by java
itself indirectly via the concept of
inheritance
if you try to do this let's try to do
this for fun and
and also for better understanding so if
i write graphic
object go equal to new
graphic object you see i don't even get
an option but let's write it
and let's see what happens so you see
that this particular
it gives basically an error because it's
not able to find the constructor of the
graphic object class
though even i have defined the default
constructor here
but still java is not able to find it
because
this class is abstract so hence proved
abstract classes cannot be instantiated
explicitly they can only be instantiated
by the
child classes through the internal
mechanisms of java
itself and that's all i want to talk
about in this particular session
where we looked in detail about the
concept of abstraction
couple of more things which i did not
cover in the previous session i just
want to call them out for clarity
java does not support multiple
inheritance
when i say multiple inheritance what it
means that
you will not have a scenario where a
child will
be extending from two base classes java
does not support it it does support it
with the with the help
of interfaces but i will talk about
interfaces in the coming sessions
but here just understand this that you
cannot
use multiple inheritance with classes in
java
a child cannot have two parent or two
base classes in java
java will not allow that it is also
called the diamond problem
because the child class does not know
whether to follow the route of base 1
plus or the base 2 class if it is
extending from 2 different
base one and base two classes so a class
can only extend from one class
in java we can find a workaround of it
by using the concept of interfaces
but that's something which will be
coming later another thing to understand
is that when you create an abstract
class
here these variables you can declare
declare these variables as well
and these variables will be accessible
by all the
child classes as you access them let's
get started
with interfaces in java now again let's
understand
what do we mean by an interface in
general and then we will see how do we
apply the concept of interfaces
in java so imagine let's let's take the
same example of vehicle industry because
that's something which we see every day
around ourselves and we can relate to it
so imagine if all the car manufacturers
were creating a different way of driving
a car
what if in one car you have a steering
but in other car you do not have a
steering but you have something else
which is which may be called something
else
in one car you have the gas pedal to
speed up
in other car you have a button to speed
up similarly in
in one car you may have different kind
of doors and in other cars you may have
different kind of doors
which are completely different looking
it's not even a single simple handle to
open it
so you see the problem here the problem
here is that all the car manufacturers
are not working on a single contract
they are not respecting a single
interface which will create a poor user
experience because the users
whenever the users have to buy a new car
or they have to switch from one
manufacturer to other manufacturer
they are completely clueless as to how
to drive that particular class
because the interface they were using in
the previous car
is completely different from the
interface they are being shown
in the other car and that's that's the
basic
need for the concept of interface think
of it as an contract agreement
you see it is also mentioned here that
if you apply the same kind of concept to
programming world
imagine if every programmer was writing
their own logic in their own way without
following
a single contract or a single guideline
soon it is going to create a problem and
that's the kind of problem
interfaces try to solve so interface is
again a keyword in java
and the basic idea or the basic
construct is that the interfaces
are going to define the specifications
of how a class would act let me repeat
this in a more generic way
interfaces are going to define the
contract
or the specification which is going to
govern
how an application or code or
programming logic will behave that's the
basic idea of interfaces
so interfaces are their own type
and the basic property of interface is
that
it can only contain constants
method declarations similar to abstract
classes
and some default methods or static
methods
or nested types what is nested type we
will cover that later
default methods will touch upon a bit
here and the static methods as well
but the basic idea is that when you
create when you create an interface in
java
you cannot write anything concrete in
terms of the behavior of the interface
when i say behavior always think of that
as method
so you cannot define a concrete method
in an interface you can only declare
methods
you can also declare constants you can
create a particular type of concrete
method by using the default keyword but
use it in very special circumstances
you can also create static methods as
well which are only going to belong to
the interface and nobody else
now let's look at an example and and
also
before we go to the example let me also
phrase this here that
if an interface cannot define a concrete
implementation
of the methods then naturally the
interface is going to
be extended by a child class a concrete
class
which is going to provide the
implementation of the methods
declared in the interface it does sound
like abstract classes
but there is a difference let's
understand the difference with the help
of an example this is how an interface
will look like
i've used the same construct of bicycle
and mountain bike
just to maintain some continuity and
less context switching
but this is how an interface would look
like you will not use the class keyword
but
instead you instead of that you will use
the interface keyword
you can only declare methods you cannot
define methods
remember when we looked at the abstract
classes example
we were able to define concrete methods
as well
but in interface that's a strict no no
you cannot
define concrete methods let me show you
the abstract class
in the case of abstraction which we used
this was the abstract class
and it did have a concrete method right
but bicycle.java here which is because
it's an interface
it is not going to allow you to create a
concrete method
another thing is that if you try to
declare a variable inside the class
they will have to be constant you cannot
just declare them without any value
for example i cannot do this if i do
this
it is going to give an error you see an
error here and it says
initialize field x at declaration
something like this public static final
so
interface is going to force you to
declare all the variables as public
static final with some value if you try
to use them inside interface
so that is also something which
interface will mandate so you see
interfaces are more strict
they are more strict in terms of what
you can do you can only declare
public static final variables and you
can only
declare methods you cannot define
methods so abstract class
is less restrictive interface is more
restrictive
and that is the differentiation which
you have to keep in mind whether to use
abstract classes or whether to use
interfaces that is also a very common
confusing question
in the interviews as well and remember
that interfaces are
only for contracts or specifications
where in case of abstract class you can
write
a concrete behavior as well in terms of
a concrete method in the base class
interfaces there's no concrete
implementation in the base class
abstract classes yes there can be a
concrete implementation in the base
class
that's the basic difference moving on i
have created a child class here
which is again mountain bike and it has
three properties
seat height gear and speed similar to
the previous example
it has a constructor and remember in
again interfaces
cannot be uh initialized directly so you
don't even need to call a
super method here because there is
nothing to initialize you initialize a
class to create a state
state is denoted by the properties but
interfaces will force you to write a
public static final property
and initialize its value automatically
so you do not need a constructor for the
interface
because there is nothing to initialize
everything has been initialized in terms
of the variables
and the methods are anywhere just
declared that's why you don't need to
call super here
after that the moment you write this
particular keyword here
implements and that is how you will
basically extend from the
from the interface you will use the
implements
bicycle keyword here implements is the
keyword and bicycle is the name of the
interface
if you write this here then java is
going to force you to provide the
implementation of these two methods if i
if i do this implements bicycle and if i
comment out
these two methods which is coming from
the base class it is going to give an
error
and if i read out this error it says
either you add the unimplemented methods
or you make the mountain bike class as
abstract there are two ways to fix this
particular class
similar to abstract classes it will
force you to write the implementation
of the base class declared methods
another thing which java will will
suggest you and will
also force you via some ides as well is
that you
use this particular annotation we use
this particular annotation to tell java
that we are overriding this method from
the base class
since apply break and speed up methods
were defined here in the base class
and this child class is supposed to
provide the implementation of the
methods
by overriding them overriding is again a
concept which we will talk about in
detail
in the coming sessions but for now
remember that you need to write this
annotation here
on the methods which have been taken
from the base class to provide an
implementation
and the implementation is similar to
what we have seen before so whatever
value you supply
in the apply break the speed is going to
get decremented by that particular value
and in case of speed up whatever value
you supply in the argument
that value is going to be added to the
current speed
and the speed is going to go up let's
look at the main class here which is
called interface demo
it has a public static void main method
and here i'm again initializing the
child class
nothing's nothing strange here and then
i'm using the getter method here
because i have made everything as
private here
and rest of the things are just here as
is i have the
getters and setters here for all the
properties and i'm using those here so
i'm using the getters to just get the
value of gear
seat height and speed and then i'm
applying the brake
and then i'm printing the current speed
after applying the brakes
let me just expand this a bit more and
then i'm using the speed up method
trying to increase the current speed of
the bike by
10 and then printing the new speed again
so using the apply break and speed up
methods
which are concretely defined in the
child class
by using this override annotation and
these were the methods which were
declared
in the interface in the base interface
and that's all it which is happening in
this particular class
let's run this particular program and
these are the values i get
i get the gear as 1 which is coming from
here
i get the seat height as 20 which is
coming from here
i get the current bike speed as 10 this
was the value which it was initialized
with
then i'm applying the brake and after
applying the brake
the speed of the bike gets reduced and
it becomes 10 minus
1 which becomes 9 and that's what gets
printed here
and then i'm speeding up the bike by 10
so the current value
of the current value of the speed of the
bike is
9 and if i incremented by 10 it becomes
19 and that's what gets printed here
let's get started with inheritance so
inheritance is basically
one of the most important properties of
any object oriented programming language
it's basically a concept
and the concept says that what if you
have a scenario
where you want multiple classes to share
similar behavior and similar properties
let's understand this with the help of
an example
let's take the example of a bank when
you go to a bank to open an account
there are multiple types of accounts
there can be a savings account
it can be a type of current account
there can also be a different
offering for personal account and
commercial accounts such as for
businesses
then you may also have loan accounts
which are having different kind of
properties
so all of these types of accounts are
still
technically accounts and they will share
some similar properties for example
all of them will have to maintain some
sort of an interest rate for example
all of them will be used to either
deposit money or
withdraw money so there would be some
kind of similarity across
all of these types of account classes
but at the same time there will also be
some sort of differentiality amongst
these classes
the way you will calculate the interest
rate for a current account
will be different from the way you will
calculate the interest rate
for a savings account and the same
applies for commercial account personal
account loan account etc so
you see that we have some common
behavior but at the same time we also
have some
different behavior so whenever you have
such scenario
always think about applying the concept
of inheritance
in your application there's another
simple way to spot whether inheritance
can be used at a particular place or not
inheritance is also called is a
relationship
so whenever you read the requirements
from a customer just try to find the
words
which use this particular phrase is a
for example
car is a vehicle savings account
is a type of account similarly you will
find many other types of similar
examples so whenever you will see that
is a relationship between
two different kinds of objects or two
different kind of
entities that means that there might be
an inheritance relationship
being applied between them and that's
how you will spot the usage of
inheritance so so far we have understood
this concept that there would be
some sort of relationship between the
two classes what will be this
relationship
the relationship will be of parent child
type there will be a parent class
some people also call that as base class
and then there will be a
child class so the child class will be
inheriting the properties
and the behaviors from the base class or
from the parent class
i will be using base class and parent
class terms interchangeably during this
session but the basic idea and basic
premise is like that only that there
will be a child class
and there will be a parent class and the
child class class
is extending from the parents class
remember the word extend because we are
going to use that and i've just shown
you the uh
what you see here is basically the
official definition which is given by
javadocs here we can read the definition
as well
and the basic idea which i told you lies
in the parent and child relationship
and this is how you can conceptualize it
that you will have
a base class or a parent class and then
you will
you can have multiple children of it and
then those children can again have their
own children
and so on so forth so this hierarchy
this whole inheritance hierarchy can go
as
deep as you want it to be and that's the
basic idea and basic
conceptualization of how you understand
and how you visualize
inheritance now let's move to eclipse
ide
and try to understand this with the help
of an example
so for this particular case i have
created
a set of classes basically which we will
be using to demonstrate the relationship
of inheritance and i've taken the simple
example of a bicycle so
a bicycle is again a very generic
definition of any two wheeler and
bicycles can have multiple types
there can be an all-terrain bike there
can be a mountain bike
there can be a city bike there can be a
bike which is specific
specifically made for ladies and
similarly there can be multiple
different types of bikes
but all of these bikes will have some
similar properties
for example all of them will have two
wheels all of them will have
a seat all of them will have brake all
of them will have
some sort of some sort of a speeding
mechanism
whether they can accelerate or
deaccelerate so there will be some
commonality but at the same time
a mountain bike's features might be very
different
from a city bike feature a mountain bike
features
might featu mountain bike might have
gears for example
whereas a city bike might not have gears
because you don't need
that much of a variation in in
inclination and declination when you
drive down the road so i'm trying to
conceptualize the same example here
where i've created a class called
bicycle
and this is my base class i define two
properties in the
in the bicycle class which is gear and
speed
we will come back to protected in a
while but let's
let's leave that there so i have two
properties which is gear and speed
i have a constructor where i'm
initializing the starting speed and the
starting gear
and then i have three methods here which
says
set gear apply break and speed up
when i apply brake the speed is going to
get reduced
so that's why you see minus equal to
unary operator
and when i'm trying to speed up the
speed is going to increase
that's why i'm using the plus equal to
unary operator so when you use the
method speed up
the speed is going to be increased by
the value you supply in the method
similarly when you apply the break the
speed is going to
get reduced by the amount you supply in
the method
argument and that is my base class
bicycle
gear speed and three methods now let's
have a look at the child class so the
way you will define the inheritance
relationship in java
is by using this extends keyword
remember i told you to remember the
extends keyword
so what you will do that you will write
your class name as usual
and then you will use extends keyword
and then you will use
the parent class name or the base class
name
so here i'm saying class mountain bike
extends bicycle
and here i am providing an additional
property remember the whole commonality
versus differentiality
equation so a mountain bike might have
an extra property
to adjust the seat height so that's the
extra property which mountain bike
is having and then since this
mountain bike is extending the bicycle
class
this mountain bike class has the
responsibility
to initialize the bicycle class as well
and the way it will fulfill that
responsibility
is by taking all the arguments
of bicycle class plus the mountain bike
class
in its constructor and that's why you
see three different properties here
you see the start height property which
is the
property of this particular class which
is the seat height and then you see the
start speed and start gear property
which directly are not available in this
class
but this class is inheriting those
properties from the
base class remember the keyword
inheritance here
and then once you do that how do you
initialize the base class constructor
is by calling the super method this is
again a keyword in java
and you will use this super keyword to
refer to
the base class constructor in this way
so what you will do technically is that
you will write super
and you will supply the arguments which
is required by the base class
constructor
if i go back the base class constructor
requires two arguments
start speed and start gear so i write
super
and then i write start speed and start
gear so whatever i got from here
in the constructor of mountain bike i'm
supplying those values as is
to super and java will automatically
take care of
invoking this particular constructor the
moment it
uh encounters this kind of statement
another another thing to notice is that
the super keyword or super statement has
to be the first statement
inside your constructor remember that
whenever you are dealing with
inheritance
and whenever you have to initialize the
super class constructor or the base
class constructor
use the super constructor invocation as
the very first statement
inside your child class constructor
otherwise java will not
compile the program and then you will
initialize the local variable
i should call this as this remember i we
discussed about this in this
in the classes session okay and then
it just has a method of set height so
there's no extra method which this
mountain bike is providing
but this mountain bike will have access
to
all the methods which have been provided
here and all the properties which have
been provided here
this mountain bike can access everything
from the bicycle class and that's the
whole idea of inheritance that
the child class can access the
properties of the base class by
extending the base class
now let's look at how do we invoke this
particular class
so for that i have a simple class name
as inheritance demo which has a public
static void main method
and then i am initializing the mountain
bike class
i am supplying three values as 20 10 and
1.
so the 20 goes to start height
the 10 here goes to start speed
and one here goes to gear
or the start gear and that's how i'm
setting the values
so when i call this particular
constructor here the mountain bike
constructor is going to
this mountain bike constructor is going
to get called and
which in turn is going to call the base
class bicycle class constructor as well
and everything will be set accordingly
and then let's try to access the gear
property remember gear is not directly
available in the mountain bike class
but i'm still able to do mountain bike
dot gear because
child class can access the parent's
class properties
similarly the same thing goes for speed
as well
and seat height is the local property of
this particular class mountain bike so
it will anyways be accessible
so i can access all the properties of
the base class
and the child class itself seamlessly
without any differentiation
now let's try to call a method so here
i'm calling the method
apply break remember apply break was
defined in the base class not in the
child class
it's defined here so i'm calling the
apply break method and
i want to reduce the speed the current
speed by
1 and then i'm printing the current
speed saying that
bike speed after applying brake is
mountain bike dot
speed so let's run this particular
program and observe the outputs
okay so the the first statement which
gets printed is at line number seven
which says gear is
one because it's coming from here then
the seat height
is mountain bike dot seat height which
is 20 which is the first
argument here and then the bike speed is
10
which is coming as here and getting
printed here and then when i apply the
brake
let's go back to the apply brake method
the logic is that whatever is the
current speed
reduce it by the value i supply in the
method
so if i supply 1 10 minus 1 becomes 9
and that becomes the current speed if i
supply 5 here
the current speed will be 10 minus 5
equal to 5. let's
insert that particular assumption as
well yes we can see that
and similarly you can access other
methods of the base class as well
if i just do control space here and you
can see apply break
is accessible set gear set height speed
up
all the methods which are defined in the
base class are accessible
in the child class as well this is the
power of inheritance
one more thing which i said i will come
back to is around the usage of protected
access modifier remember when we
discussed about the access modifiers in
the previous session
i said that protected is used when you
are dealing with inheritance
that whenever you define something as
protected it will be available
to be accessible in the child classes of
the base class
so if i define this particular variable
as as protected
then this particular property will be
accessible in the child class
mountain bike as well let's play around
this let's make this as private and see
what happens
so if i make this private now when i say
private the
scope of this particular variable is
within the class only and nobody outside
the class will be able to see it
and you can see the effect of it i can
see an error being coming here in my
inheritance demo
class because now mountain bike object
cannot access the gear property because
the gear property is defined in the base
class and now it is private
that's why the child class now mountain
bike class cannot access
the property gear and the moment you
make make it back to
protected it will be accessible the
error is gone there's no red line here
so that's how you can you can use the
protected
access modifiers it is always always
recommended to use them when you when
you
write any kind of inheritance logic and
inheritance logic as well intentionally
if you want to hide a particular
property from the child classes just
make it private
and that's all i want to cover in this
particular session where we
dive deep into the concept of
inheritance we had a look at an example
using the bicycle and mountain bike
kind of construct and you can apply the
same kind of construct on any kind of
other
other kind of business requirement
remember that is a relationship let's
get started with
working through a particular project
using all the concepts which we have
learned so far
so in this session we are going to focus
on a particular project
and the project we are going to focus is
is about an atm application
so you might have interacted with
different atm stores
in your cities where you go in you
insert your card you enter your pin
and then you can view the balance you
can withdraw
some amount you can also deposit some
amount from the atm
so we will try to look at it from that
perspective and and we will see what
kind of different
uh java and oops concepts we can use to
build such
atm application this is not a super
versatile application but
but this is just to give you the idea of
how to use
those oops concepts to build a simple or
a complex java application so let's
start from the
options menu class because that will
give us the understanding of what kind
of functionality i'm using
and here you will use that i am using
different concepts which i
which i have taught you so far in this
particular series
so for example we are using the i o
exception we are using
the hashmap class we are also using a
scanner class which is used to take
input from the command line so this
option menu class is extending the
account class
and i will come to the account class in
a while but let's see what this option
menu class is doing
this particular class has uh it is using
a decimal format money format class
which is to denote what kind of format
of money you have
then we have a hash map which is storing
the couple of
records of account number to pin mapping
so
we create a map and inside the get login
method
we add couple of entries to the map here
the first entry the first
integer is pointing to the customer
number and the second integer
is pointing to the pin of the account of
this particular
customer number so if we call the get
login method
this method will insert the data after
that it will ask the customer to enter
the
customer number which has to be one of
these two if you provide any other value
then there should be a logic in the
application to reject the input
so whatever a customer number the
customer inputs we pass that inside this
particular method called set customer
number
again i will come back to that and once
you have provided a valid customer
number
then this method is going to ask you to
enter a pin number
and remember i told you this is the
customer number to the pin number
mapping
so whatever customer number you select
from here you will be providing the
corresponding pin number
and again if you provide an invalid pin
number you will get an error
so that will all happen inside this try
block and
if you enter any invalid characters in
the pin number or the atm
uh customer number then you will get an
exception which i
am writing inside the catch block this
is all what we have seen so far
after the successful enter of the
customer number and the pin number
i fetch those values from these two
methods again i will talk about what
these methods are doing
and again i'm doing some basic
validation checks but things get
interesting in this method
so what we covered so far was the get
login method let me close this method
here
so we covered the get login method the
second method which is defined in this
particular class is the account type
so here that we will ask the once the
customer has provided the customer
number and the pin number
we will ask the customer to provide the
account type
this application supports two different
account types which are checking account
or a savings account
so whatever so the customer has to
choose one of them
again we will be taking the input from
the command line using the scanner class
and then i'm using a switch case if the
customer entered 1
then i will execute some code for the
checking account which is defined here
in the case 1
and if the customer entered 2 then the
case 2
will be executed and if the if it enters
three
then i will exit the application by just
printing a sys out
so here i'm using the switch case
construct to provide different options
to the customer
there's also a default case specified
here which says invalid choice
so this is what is happening in the get
account type method
the next method is if the customer has
used
the option one then we call the get
checking method
so let's go to the get checking method
which is the next method which is
defined in this particular class
so if the customer has selected a
checking account then we provide the
following functionality to the customer
which is the customer can view the
balance customer can withdraw the funds
customer can deposit the funds to the
checking account
or they can just exit the application
and again i'm using a switch case here
based on the customer types one two
three or four
the corresponding case block will be
executed for example if the customer
wants to view the balance
then this block will get executed and i
call the get account type method
if the customer selects the to as the
withdraw fund
then get checkings with withdraw input
method gets called and then
get account type gets called similarly
if the customer
enters three then we deposit the fund
and for that also i have defined a
method i will go to the definition of
these methods
as we go along but right now we are just
building the framework
so the get checking deposit input method
will be called whenever the customer
selects the option three
and for option four we just exit the
application so this is
what is happening in the get checking
method now if from the account selection
if the customer selected
second option which was savings account
then we were calling get saving method
so this is where the get saving method
is defined and again it is following the
exact same
format as we saw in the get checking
method where we
present the following options like
viewing balance withdrawing the funds
and depositing the funds in the savings
account
and i have some methods defined here for
example get saving
withdraw input get saving deposit input
so we define the switch case here based
on the customer's choices here and that
is what is happening in the get saving
method so let me close this method as
well
and that's all what is defined inside
the option menu class
so we ask the customer to enter the
customer number the pin number from this
get login method
then based on that we provide the
customer the options to choose the
account type
whether they can choose the savings
account or the checking account and
based on that
whatever account type they use we call
the get checking or
get saving method and inside this method
we provide the customer
the other options to either withdraw the
money deposit the money or view the
balance
that is what is happening inside this
option menu class now let's go to the
account class and all the methods which
we saw here
will be provided a definition in the
account class you also see this option
menu
is extending the accounts class so an
inheritance concept is being used here
let's go to the account class now so
this is the account class
where i have defined some private member
variables like customer number
so now you will be familiar with the
customer number pin number which i just
described
and also with the checking balance and
the savings balance
you can also divide this account class
into two child classes
where you have a savings account class
and a checking account class
but for simplicity i've kept it to one
class i'm initializing a scanner input
which will be used at multiple places
and then i have the setters and getters
for these four
member variables so you see set customer
number get customer number
if you remember this set customer number
was called in the option menu class
if i go back to the get login once we
ask the customer to enter the customer
number
we call the set customer number which
gets called here similarly
we call the set pin number which gets
called here
similarly once we have said that we then
we were fetching the values
using the get customer number and the
get pin number and that has
that is also defined here in terms of
the getters get pin number and get
customer number
similarly we also have the getters for
the checking balance and the saving
balance
member variables we do not have the
setters for them because
they are not technically setters but we
have to calculate the balance
it's not a simple setter where you can
just return the value
so now let's look at some of the
business functions of the account class
how do you deposit how do you view the
balance how do you withdraw the balance
etc
so you see these two methods which are
specifically
when the customer is trying to withdraw
the money from their account
and these methods are basically called
internally by other methods
so we will come to that let's see that
let's just understand that we have two
methods
for calculating the withdrawal amount or
executing the withdrawal transaction for
the checking account
account and the savings account
similarly i have two more methods here
which are calculating the
depositing for the checking account and
calculating
the depositing for the savings account
and then we get
the the bigger methods which are using
these calculation methods
so i define four calculation methods so
far calc checking withdraw
calc saving withdraw calc checking
deposit and calc saving deposit
basically we're drawing in deposit for
both of the classes
and then we have these business
functions called get checking
withdraw input and get saving withdraw
input
get checking deposit input and get
saving deposit input so these getter
methods are something which were being
called from the option menu class if you
remember
if you go back to the option menu class
and if you chose the checking account
you get these options and let's say you
chose option 2
which was withdraw funds or option 3
which was
deposit funds then the corresponding
methods which were being called were
get checking withdraw input and get
checking
deposit input and this is the exact same
method get checking withdraw input
and get checking deposit input so if you
see what is happening inside this
particular method
is couple of sysouts then we take the
scanner input amount and we convert that
amount to the double
after that we check if the amount which
the customer wants to withdraw
is smaller than the checking balance or
not and i'm running this condition to
check that
if the amount is smaller than the
checking balance
then we call the calc checking withdraw
method
which was defined right here remember i
told you that these four calc methods
will be used
and this is how they are used so here
i'm actually subtracting the value so
whatever
amount the customer wants to withdraw
subtract that from the main balance
and then return the new main balance
that's what you do right if you have
thousand rupees and if you want to
withdraw 500
you subtract 500 from thousand and then
you send back the remaining balance
so that is what is happening when we
call this method and then we print the
new checking account balance
that is what is happening in the get
checking withdraw input method
similarly if you chose option 3 which
was depositing funds to the checking
account then get
checking deposit input gets called and
it is defined
right here get checking deposit input
and here instead of subtraction
we are doing the addition so here i'm
again doing a condition check that
the current balance plus the new amount
which has been supplied by the customer
from the command line
the total sum of it should be greater
than zero what if the customer
entered an amount minus 5000 i should
not allow that
so that's the reason i'm putting this
condition in place and if
the current balance plus the new amount
which is supposed to be deposited to the
account the sum of it
is greater than zero then call the calc
checking
deposit method and this is where the
calc checking deposit method is present
and where i'm just going present balance
plus the new amount and returning the
new balance
that's all which is being done here and
you will see exactly similar logic
running for the
savings account as well if you look at
the get saving withdraw input
which is used to withdraw money from the
savings account so i take the input from
the command line
and i run a condition check that the
amount which the customer wants to
withdraw
should be less than the current saving
accounts balance
if yes then call calc saving saving
withdraw method
which is defined here whereby subtract
the amount from the current balance and
i return the new balance
and similarly you will see the exact
same functionality in the
get saving deposit where we add the
money instead of
subtracting the money and this is all
what is defined in the account class
so we talked about the option menu class
we talked about the account
class and now we have the atm class
which is the entry point
which basically initializes the option
menu class
and calls the get login method remember
get login was the first method which
asked you to provide the customer number
and then get login called
the method to choose the account type
and the account type methods then called
the method
to choose the option to withdraw deposit
or exit
so now we have built a fair
understanding of what is happening in
this application
so let's run this application so i just
ran this application and let me bring
the console here
it's first asking for a customer number
so i will go to the option menu
class and i will pick up one of the
customer number which i have hard coded
here
so i will provide that customer number
and hit enter then it asks me for the
pin number
so remember you have to provide the
correct pin number corresponding to the
customer number
so i'm taking this pin number just
copying it and pasting it here
then this whole code got executed and
then it called the get account type
and the get account type method provided
you with these options
which you see here on the screen so
based on what you select
the case block will get executed and
let's say i want
to go for a checking account so i press
one
and i hit enter once you select the
checking account the case one gets
selected and it calls the get
checking method and the get checking
method again provides you with another
menu to withdraw
view view withdraw or deposit or exit so
let's say i want to
deposit funds so i press 3 and hit enter
it says the current balance is 0 and
enter the amount you want to
deposit let's say i want to deposit 500
and i hit
enter you get the message saying the new
checking account balance is 500 and you
have successfully deposited the money
and that is what i did for the checking
account now let's try to withdraw
something from the ticking account so
you again get back the same option
because
inside the get checking method we call
the once we have successfully done the
business operation we again
call the account type method to display
the menu again to the user so let's see
again select the checking account class
and this time i want to withdraw the
funds remember i've added 500 there
so let's say i want to withdraw so i
choose the option 2
as the choice current balance is 500 and
it's asking me the amount you want to
withdraw from the checking account
so i enter let's say 100 and i hit
enter when i do that the new checking
account balance becomes 400
so the 100 got subtracted from the 500
and the new balance
is shown to your screen you can do
exactly the same thing for for the
savings account as well and
let's also run a negative condition so i
again select the checking account
and i want to withdraw the funds so
i choose the option to current balance
is 400 and i
i would like to withdraw a thousand what
happens if you do that we get a message
saying balance cannot be negative and
this is coming from the calc checking
method which
which is defined here so what is
happening that i wanted to withdraw the
funds from the checking account
and here get checking withdraw
input.called
here this condition was checked so the
checking balance
was 400 and the amount i wanted to
withdraw
was 1000. so 400 minus 1000 is not
greater than equal to 0. so it jumped
into the else block and it said
balance cannot be negative so this is
how you can also build some error
conditions in your code which are
mandatory and which should be built
otherwise your application will have lot
of bugs
we can also exit the application so if
you just type 3 and hit
enter you will exit from the application
and it will come in it will again call
the
login method where it will again ask you
to enter the customer number
so this is how you can run this
application and this is this was a
simple use case for you to show
how you can use the different
object-oriented concepts like classes
objects methods setters getters switch
case
etc to build the application with the
correct business logic
let's get started with working through a
code java project
using all the different oops concept we
have learned so
far so in this example we are going to
have a look at a calculator application
and this calculator application supports
primarily four different operations
like addition subtraction multiplication
and
division so let's see how do we build
that app
so in front of me right now is open the
main class
so i have a main app class here which
has a public static void main method
and the first thing we see is a read
input class which is
calling a read method so if you go to
the read input class
it has a simple static method here which
is the read method
and it is using the scanner class if you
remember i talked about the scanner
class which is used to take
inputs from the command line from the
user so
we initialize the scanner class and we
start taking the inputs
and whatever the user inputs in terms of
the expression
let's say the user entered 4 plus 5 or
whatever that whole expression
gets sent back into this input line as a
string
and that comes back here in that input
expression
once we have captured the input
expression the next thing we do
is divide the input expression in the
numbers and the operators
basically an expression would be either
something like
4 plus 5 into 3
divided by 2 let's say let's say the
user entered this expression
so this has either numbers or operators
so that's what we are doing here we are
using the split method of the string
api the string class basically and this
split method is going to split the
numbers and operators into two different
string arrays
and here i am providing the split
expression that split at every time
you encounter one of these symbols so
this when you execute this particular
statement it is going to return a
numbers array
which will be created based on this
expression so you will get an array with
4
5 3 and 2 and similarly in the
operator array you are going to split or
pick out the elements
every time you receive a number so this
operator array is going to hold
this plus sign this multiply sign and
this divide sign
hope you get the understanding that we
are just splitting the whole expression
into two different
arrays where first array is holding only
the numbers and
no mathematical expressions and second
array is just holding the mathematical
operators
and no numbers and we'll see why we need
to do that in the upcoming lines
once i have created this string array i
just want to
store or convert these string arrays
into a queue
so i convert this array into a list by
calling the array
dot as list so this expression is going
to return a list
and then i'm going to convert this
normal list
into a linked list and then going to
store this linked list
into the queue of numbers and i'm going
to do exactly the same thing
for the operator array as well
converting this into a generic list
converting that generic list into a
linked list and then storing this linked
list as a queue
so i have an operators queue and i have
a numbers queue both of them have been
stored into a queue now
and then i'm using the poll method if
you remember the poll method of the
queue
is used when you want to fetch the first
front element the head element of the
queue so whichever element is sitting at
the head of the queue will be taken out
the moment you call call the poll method
so i fetch the first number from the
numbers q
so in this case 4 will be fetched here
in this variable and after that i run a
loop
on the numbers q and i'm going to run
this
particular loop till this particular
queue is
not empty if you see there's a negation
here so i'm going to pick up numbers one
by one
from this numbers queue till the number
q becomes
empty and inside the loop i do the exact
same poll operation
for the operations queue so this
operations queue is holding
all these mathematical operations like
plus
star and divide so i'm going to pick the
head of it
so in this case plus will be picked up
and will be stored in this variable
called opr
and then i am going to run a switch case
on this opr
basically as i told you in this
particular calculator application
we are supporting four operations which
are addition subtraction
multiplication and division so i define
a case
for each of the mathematical expression
so you see there are four different
cases here and for each case
i'm initializing a class if it's a plus
sign
then i'm initializing the add class if
it's a minus sign
then i'm initializing the subtractors
for multiplication
i have a class called multiply and for
division i have a class called
divide let's have a look at what these
classes are containing
so if i go to the add class first of all
it is implementing an interface called
operate
and this operator interface has just a
single method called get results
which is accepting a variable argument
array if you remember i told you that
you can also use a
array this is called a where arc
expression this means
that this numbers will be an array of
arbitrary
length it can be a one element array it
can be a two element array
it can be a four element array or
whatever you supply but it is still
going to be a fixed length array
but the length is going to be dependent
upon how much
argument you supply to this particular
method so that is what this interface
operate is doing
it just has one method declared which is
called get result which is accepting an
array of numbers
so if the add class is implementing the
operator interface
then it has to override the get result
method
and here it is just doing a summation of
all the numbers which have been supplied
so if you supply four numbers it is just
going to add up those four numbers
and return the sum and the exact same
kind of logic or similar logic will be
seen
in other operate classes so if i go to
the subtract class
it runs the exact same operation but it
subtracts the values
if i go to the multiply class it is also
implementing the operate interface
and in the get result it is just
multiplying all the values
similarly in the divide class it is also
implementing the operator interface
and it is dividing all the numbers one
by one so it's doing pretty much the
same thing
in terms of the expression and the logic
the only difference is whether you are
using an add operation or a subtract or
multiply or a divide
so we have checked all these classes and
the operator interface as well
and let's go back to the main app now
now you also see that i've defined a
reference of operate here
and each of the switch case block i'm
assigning
the object type to this interface
reference
so i'm using the concept of dynamic
binding which we talked about when we
talked about interfaces
that we can also do dynamic binding
where we can
assign an object to an interface type
and the object type will depend upon the
expression
so once we have filled that based on the
case while
filtering out this expression and
picking up plus star and divide
sequentially then we go to the next line
outside the switch case block
which is to pick the next number from
the queue
remember we already did one poll here so
as per this example
4 was here in this res and now when we
do this
number dot poll again 5 will be picked
up because that will be the next head of
the queue so we pick up 5 here
and then we call operate dot get result
now this get result will be called based
on the expression
which was encountered first in the queue
again looking at the example the first
expression encountered will be
plus so the expression was plus so
the operate type object is of ad type
and when you call operate dot get result
the get result method of
add class is going to get invoked and it
is going to
sum four and five this rest is holding
four right now
based on what i described here
numbers.poll
and this num is holding the
the second operand basically basically 5
here
so 4 plus 5 gets evaluated here in this
case
and then it again goes back here and it
checks if the number q is
now empty no it is still not empty
because we still have 3
n2 left there so again it does the
operations operations.poll and it picks
up multiply sign here
then it again runs the switch case since
it's a multiply sign
it will go here and it will initialize
the operate interface reference as
the object of multiply class then coming
here it will do a numbers
dot poll and this time the numbers dot
poll is going to pick up 3
so 3 will be picked up here and then the
current value of result
which is already 9 4 plus 5 was 9 the
current value of result will be updated
here so rest will be 9 here
and num will be 3 here and when you call
operate dot get result
the multiply classes get result will get
called
and it will say 9 into 3 which will
become 27
it will again go back here to this
particular line and it will check again
if the numbers queue is now empty no it
is still not empty because we still have
one element left
then it pulls uh the queue of the
operations
where the expression divide is present
there which is the only element left in
this particular operations queue
and since we have the opr value as
divide this
case block gets called and the new
divide class gets initialized the divide
class basically gets initialized
and we come here and we do numbers.poll
now the last number which is available
in this queue is
2 which gets picked up here and then we
again
call operate.getresult this time since
the operate object
refer object operator reference type was
of divide
class type so when we call
operate.getresult
the divide operation or the getresult
method of the divide class
basically this method will get invoked
and it will divide the current value of
result
which was 4 plus 5 9 into 3
which was 27 so it is going to divide 27
by 2 which was the last value
of the numbers dot pole so it is
it is going to execute 27 by 2 and
whatever value it gets it is going to
store the
value back into the rest variable and
then it is again going to go back here
and again going to check the condition
if the numbers q is
not empty but now the numbers queue is
empty because 2 was the last element
so it is going to come out of the loop
and it is going to print the
final result that is how this whole
program is working
now let's try to see this in action and
will try to execute the exact same
expression
so if i right click and go to run as and
run this as java application
and i supply an expression saying 4 plus
5 star 3 divide
2 and if i now hit enter i get the value
as 13.5
which is exactly what we ran through
because 4 plus 5
will be evaluated first which will
result into 9
then 9 into 3 will be 27 and 27 divided
by 2
will be 13.5 exactly so this is how this
whole program is running
where we first take the inputs and then
we divide the input into
numbers and operation arrays or in fact
queues
and once we have those queues built up
then we pick up the first number
and we keep running this loop till the
numbers q
is not empty inside the while loop at
each step
we pick up the first expression or the
operator
we check what is the operator whether it
is an addition subtraction
multiplication or division operator
and whatever kind of operator we have we
initialize the corresponding class of it
and then we fetch the next
value in the numbers q and then we call
the get result
based on the expression and whatever
result we get
from the get result we store it back
into the rest variable so we keep
updating the rest variable at every step
that's the reason the result of 4 plus 5
gets stored in the rest
and next time you are calling the get
result for a multiply operation
here the rest value is 9 now and it says
9 into 3
again in the next time the rest value
will be updated to 27
because we are storing the result back
into the result variable
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session where we
looked at an example of a calculator
application purely from the console
standpoint obviously there can be lot
more stuff which we can do into this
particular
application make it more error-free and
cover a lot of corner cases like
validating the inputs
etc also looking at or putting some
conditions around the exception handling
handling the divide by zero scenario etc
which is not here but this is just to
show you the basic idea of how you can
build
simple to complex cli applications using
the core java concepts
so that's all i want to cover in this
particular session if you like this
video
a thumbs up will be massively
appreciated thank you and will meet
again
in the next session and with that we
have come to an end of this particular
tutorial on
object-oriented programming in java if
you have any queries regarding the
topics covered in this session
then please feel free to ask them down
in the comment section below our team of
experts
will be happy to resolve all your
queries until next time
thank you stay safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here